we tend to operate with the view that
the best way to please people is not to
bother them too much
we keep many of our dilemmas and
confusions away from those we like for
fear of irritating or inconveniencing
them and so spoiling the relationship we
may well have a voice echoing in our
minds from childhood don't bother your
mother can't you see she's exhausted
from her trip or don't bother your
father he works hard for us and he's
busy right now there are powerful
reasons why we equate making others
happy with burdening them as little as
possible but our analysis is missing a
key detail of human psychology we like
to be bothered
not at all times and over all things nor
at the expense of our own critical needs
but fundamentally we have a powerful
urge to feel helpful we need to be
needed all of us suffer from a fear of
superfluity which the requirements of
others has a critical capacity to
appease however nice presence may be for
our friends the real gift we can offer
them is an insight into our problems we
can pick this theme up in the realm of
work the dominant societal story is that
we work strictly for ourselves for our
status and our financial benefit but in
reality more puzzlingly but far more
beautifully what really makes our work
feel exciting and meaningful is the
power it gives us to help other people
work is at its most gratifying when it
affords us a feeling that we have over
the course of a day managed to appease
the suffering or increase the pleasure
of another person there are so many
stories of being exhausted by the
requests of others too few of the
delight we experience when we turn
around someone else's to stress boredom
or craving we can't ultimately feel are
valuable sides until we're called upon
to exercise them we don't have a sense
of our strength until someone else needs
us to lift something we can't feel
intelligent until someone asked us to
solve an issue we can't feel wise until
we've been brought in to adjudicated
asst
buuuut we rely on the needs of others to
remind us of what we're capable what
holds true in professional life applies
as much to personal experience the best
way to charm and break the ice with a
new person we like the look of in a
public place isn't to try to say
something witty or soothing we should
strive to bring them a question we
should ask them whether we're in the
right line whether they know when the
post office opens or if they have any
idea how long chicken this size might
need in an oven with closer friends - we
should dare to reveal our amusement we
should ask them if they could possibly
spare a moment then solicit their views
on what we might do about our angry
teenage child or how we should cope with
a sexless relationship or what they'd
advise us about a colleague who's prone
to panic our questions won't probably be
a burden they will show that we're ready
to make ourselves vulnerable in their
eyes and therefore that we trust and
think them wise this isn't just a
cynical strategy for ingratiating
ourselves it isn't Machiavellian or sly
we genuinely all need help we aren't
pretending to have problems and making
up a few just a flutter we're suffering
inside but simply generally don't dare
to reveal the truth for fear of driving
people away and yet we are staying
guarded out of an ideal of
self-sufficiency that isn't either true
to our needs or constructive for the
well-being and esteem of others so we
should risk doing what we at heart have
always longed to do to reveal some of
the fear sadness and angst we genuinely
feel to those we care about we will be
helped in our pain we will remind others
of their capacities and if we're
fortunate
we'll set a precedent that means that
others will one day bring a few of their
problems to us in turn
thank you for watching remember to like
the video and please subscribe to our
channel for more
you